there's a lot of climate exaggeration
you know that climate is not the end of
the planet so the planet's going to be
fine here's a generic intro to a clip we
wanted to show you so in closing give us
your level of optimism at this point are
we going to be okay well the there's a
lot of climate exaggeration you know
that climate is not the end of the
planet so the planet's going to be fine
uh we're not going to completely reverse
development so you know when we went
from 10 million kids dying per year in
the year 2000 down to 5 million we're
not going to reverse that it's going to
slow down our progress and so things
like climate adaptation which doesn't
get hardly any uh visibility that's
become very important for the poor
countries and yes it is a burden on them
a significant burden on them that you
know it's not they didn't create the
problem we created the problem so this
is all numbers uh you know will we hit
1.5 5° no will we hit 3° no we'll be
below we'll be in that range the lower
the better and the you know the sense of
progress it's important for people to
see that emissions in many areas have
come down and at least at the lab level
we have economic solutions for every
kind of
emission